Speaker 1: Let's go to the state of Georgia.
I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly. Is
it hanau? Is that the right pronunciation?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Sorry. Hi, it's Hannah. It
just felt weird because my mom's
family is the Netherlands. Oh, okay.
But, yeah, so sorry. I'm super nervous.
Speaker 1: I mean, you're doing great.
Speaker 2: So, Georgia, like I was, I wasn't born
here, but I grew up here. Like, even when I moved
in high school, I came back here for college
and to be with my family and friends. And,
like, just though, like, the rate they're
going, like, I'm like as a person able to
get pregnant and I'm like a mother of
a daughter. I'm honestly petrified to
stay in Georgia or really even the U.S.. If
it keeps going down the route, we're going.
Um, and so like, but I'm sure, like, I have like
an idealized version of other countries. So,
like, I was just wondering, like, are there any
countries that you're, like, confident in, like
their, you know, level of education and government
regulation? Yeah, like standard of living, things
like that. And then I did have one other question.
Speaker 1: So listen here. Here's the thing. There
is a a metric called the Human Development Index.
Okay. And I hear you saying, you know, you're
worried about Georgia, but maybe you're worried
about the entire U.S.. I do think it's important
to understand that in the U.S., if you search
for U.S. states ranked by HDI, you will find that
at the top of the list, you have Massachusetts,
Connecticut, Minnesota, New Jersey, New Hampshire,
Colorado. These are states whose HDI is
equivalent to that of places like Switzerland,
Norway. Iceland. Hong Kong. Australia. Denmark.
Sweden. And those are all very good places to
be. Human Development Index is basically a kind of
like a blended metric that takes into account life
expectancy, education, income, health, a bunch
of it's like a blended metric. Those states I
mentioned and really everything from like, you
know, roughly like Oregon and Up, which is like,
you know, about 18 states or so. It's not
that different than some of the best places
in the world to live. The problem is that at the
bottom of the list, it gets very bad, right. And
it's mostly red states. It's Mississippi, West
Virginia, Alabama, Arkansas, Kentucky, Louisiana,
South Carolina, Tennessee, Oklahoma. You know,
you get the picture. Georgia's down there as well.
Things are much, much worse. So one thing is
it's hard to move to other countries. So I would
look at, is there a state you can move to where
abortion rights are safe, education is better,
access to health care is better. And the answer
is there are many such states. If you want to
look internationally, then you're looking at some
of the countries I just mentioned. But it's quite
difficult to move to some of those places.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Well, I think I just worry
more about, like, not even just like
down to the particular states, but like
what? They're coming after a national level.
Speaker 1: I understand. I understand. The
truth is, even with that, there are many states
in which you are protected against a lot of those
things. Not all of them. Yeah. Social Security.
You're not going to be protected no matter what
state you're in if they got it. But, you know,
you don't have to run away screaming just just
yet. I'll tell you if the time comes for that.
Speaker 2: Okay. Yeah. And I did have one more
question about, like, how to kind of
like, appeal to MAGA people, like. Yep.
From Democrats.
Speaker 1: Sure.
Speaker 2: So would trying to like I know
that obviously they like a lot of them have
very confused moral compasses. Yes. But
like if you're trying to appeal to them,
like on a human standpoint because like obviously
saying you're wrong or like you're not, you know,
you're you're dumb, stuff like that isn't going
to appeal to them. It's just going to irritate
them. So, like, maybe trying to go about like
Democrats coming from a standpoint of, you know,
I'm sorry that these politicians have manipulated
you and lied to you to steal, you know, to take
your vote for their own personal power and greed.
Speaker 1: I like.
Speaker 2: That idea. Like present, like
actual real life. How it would affect,
like, democratic policies would affect your
daily life, not just these two broad or two
anecdotal versions of these scenarios.
Speaker 1: I totally understand the idea.
I think it's a good one, but understand that a lot
of these folks aren't going to want to accept that
they were tricked and lied to. But your instinct
is a good one. Your instinct is not to just start
beating people over the head with facts. Hannah,
I got to run, but I really appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: Yeah, thank you. All right.
Speaker 1: Hannah from Georgia. That does
it for calls today. We will take
calls again, I promise you that.